welcome back to drew's news we have a
legend at the desk she's a writer with
many best-selling titles under her belt
a little book called sex in the city
launched one of the biggest cultural
phenomenons of our time please welcome
candace push now
oh my gosh i am i'm so thrilled to be
here because we saw each other at a
fashion show and i said can you come on
the show and i said i'd love to and you
made it happen
girl
you've got the power
unlike mark cuban who i shyly did not
approach we were lucky enough to get to
converse and
i mean i'm such a
fan and an admirer of sex in the city
and i'm curious
where your book ends and the series
continues to go on
what is your feelings and opinions of
everything i mean you literally launched
a cultural phenomenon well it's it's
actually it's been amazing and it's
amazing that you know the show has
lasted for so long and so many different
iterations
but you know at the same time
sex in the city is actually a small part
of my career
and i've written
several best-selling books and i've had
two other tv shows lipstick jungle yep
and the carrie diaries
and
my new book and my new stage show which
i wrote and performed in called is there
still sex in the city is really about an
exploration of
the sex and the city woman
in her 50s and 60s
so that's something that
i'm going to continue with that and try
to turn that into a tv series
uh one thing that i do love is again
relationships and being the queen of new
york dating and columns and everything
that you are and do i was wondering if
you would hit two dating headlines with
us i absolutely would fantastic let's
take it away you got the first headline
okay i think i have to put in my glasses
cute
okay there's so many new dating terms
it's hard to keep track
now elite daily reports that there's a
word for when you get all dressed up
hair done makeup ready dressed to the
nines
only to have your date text and cancel
it's called glam boozled that's cute
and a dating survey says that 58 of
daters say they've been glambozzled a
good rule of thumb is if you haven't
heard from him an hour before the date
hold off on those lashes
now the question is have either one of
you been glambozzled or have you been
the glam boozler no try it you try you
try to glamboozle me you better show up
with a receipt a doctor's note or a neck
brace i'm sorry not not happening you
don't get a date number two how many
people in the audience have been
glambozzled
not that many of us either we're not
being honest or we're there's a very
lucky audience here
okay who is glam boozled
no one's gonna admit did somebody admit
that yes you did
i love it you have a microphone and a
camera coming to you aren't you so glad
you raised your hands
[Laughter]
why did you glambozzle someone
i got nervous and scared
we've all done it
you're all liars
wow how interesting that is because you
got nervous and scared see it wasn't
even about the other person and that's
why someone's gonna take that and be
like what's wrong with me that's what i
did someone stood me up and i thought
god did they hear something about me or
and i went through this whole laundry
list and i just thought you know what
no
they don't know me they don't know
anything about me and this is on them
and i just need to carry on with my
afternoon and not make this a reason to
self-loathe forget it bye-bye
all right what about this you guys vogue
is asking this important question what
do you call the person that you've just
started dating well when when kerry
dated the russian on sex the city
remember she said i've taken a lava you
remember that alexander petrovsky of
course yes
but that that quote doesn't work for
everybody because if you just say that's
the person i'm dating that can feel
clunky right so vogue vogue suggests
some other options they call them your
flame your extended fling your suitor
your crush i just oh god i don't like
any of these i feel like my future
ex-husband oh that's good
problem solved right i think though if
you're starting to call
who you're just seeing something they're
going to stop calling you back because
that just seems like too much pressure
no
i yes i could well for me the word lover
is that is a strange
thing to
for me to call somebody because it feels
like it's french nothing against french
people
um and also something that when you're
married you have lovers like i always
think of french married people having
lovers right oh like it's very
like you're a couple
like adulterer yes exactly okay
well i would say
i would just call it yay
[Applause]
out on the road later this year so make
sure to look out for that and don't get
clamboozled or don't glamboozle and
let's all be good to each other and
we'll be right back
[Music]
you